[Music]
it's been a great year since we were
last together at necks and I'm really
happy to see all the amazing momentum
with our partners and our customers and
all of you you know we wanted to make
this keynote for all of you the
developers the operators the analysts
the data scientists like this is for you
who here makes apps raise your hand make
apps yeah how about how about mobile
apps what we'll have to test a lot a lot
of hands how about who's on pager duty
right now found out I was earlier today
who works with data data scientists and
analysts Yeah right on okay good news
you are all in the right place and there
is incredible incredible demand for all
of your skills and in fact there was
recently a job survey with indeed comm
and Google cloud was the fastest growing
technology would demand up over 66% from
last year so we've been out in the
community learning with you
community's been running cloud study
jams been in one of those we've done
more than pretty cool
more than 900 of these community run
learning events just just this year so
far this year and we're the 22,000 of
you have gotten involved and you're
learning from your peers which which i
think is really wonderful
um now some of you are newly certified
do some certified people in the house
with the blue jackets all right good job
good job actually you're gonna have
great jobs you're gonna have awesome
jobs so okay this keynote today is all
about that feeling you get when you make
something new kind of a magic you saw in
the opening video it really no matter no
matter what title you have if you get
your hands on the keyboard and you make
things and you do the the building and
the testing and the monitoring and the
operating this keynote is for you and
you've come to the right place so
there's so much going on right now if
you think about it serverless functions
service mesh containers ai api's auto ml
hybrid cloud it's kind of a lot of noise
right
what's what's the core behind all that
what's it's about enabling you the
developers to be the real stars getting
all of you back to the heart of
development and operations coding apps
and automating infrastructure as a
developer you're being flooded with
messages and you probably feel like
there's always a new buzzword to chase
right so what we wanted to do today is
cut through all of that noise because in
the end it's really simple it's about
helping you get great work done but have
a great time doing it
so we call that getting to the fun part
so with that let's get started as one of
our awesome developer advocates Mandy
Waite come on out and and walk us
through it Eddy
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
hi Annie how you doing thanks for coming
thank you yeah thanks for having me
so uh you're a developer and operations
background and you spent lots of time
inside and outside of Google talking to
developers
what do developers want well has a
really good question
we think in Spanish import least from my
point of view it's that sense of
excitement that everyone feels when they
build and run their first program that's
the feeling that we want every day
the feeling of learning something new
trying something new and then building
something new and it's not just that we
want our work to matter to make a
difference to our team or our company or
maybe even the world the stuff gets in
the way when we end up spending a whole
bunch of our time on things that not
only don't really matter to the business
they're also kind of boring so what do
you call it micro services DevOps manage
databases serverless or CI CD well these
things all we have in common is they let
us as developers get to the fun part so
have less sword-fighting a more creation
less hassle a more reward to get to the
fun part so you're saying when like I
get my code down check in half like a
really long build process now waiting
for the compiler that's not that's not
that's not the fun part
uh how about like I need my app to scale
and not fall over so I gotta like
configure sharding the database that's
not the thumpa okay got a big Java app
and I have to get like the VM size right
so I don't pay too much but it doesn't
worry know what the fun pop okay i go in
i go in how about you have to rewrite
the entire app because management said
move to a different cloud that stephanie
notathome huh Mandy what's the fun part
I'm so glad y'all let me bring on my
team my dad my team I will show everyone
all right thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you know what's the most fun it's
working together as a team to build
amazing apps so let's do that together
at Google we're developers - and they
want to make it as easy as possible for
you to stay in the fun zone
of coding apps I also makes in a way all
of the boring parts this way we can all
spend our time on innovation so today
we're gonna show you how Google cloud
platform helps you get to the fun will
show you how to make deploying apps to
virtual machines in the cloud easy or
use brand new Google products to make
kubernetes simpler and we'll show you
how you can use service to go faster
some apps have more traditional needs
while others benefit from modern
technologies such as kubernetes and
service so we'll work through each of
these in our demos all right so let's
stop talking and have some fun building
an application Nick is one of our
developers and he's been leading our
cloud migration efforts hey Nick what
are you working on
hey Mandy my team and I have been
building in an implementation of
Conway's Game of Life and we built it in
a few different pieces we have a web
tier front-end that's what you access
from your laptop or your mobile phone we
have a back-end that runs on Google
compute engine that's the part I've been
working on I wrote it in go that's my
favorite language we have an API layer
that runs in Cuba Nettie's and finally
we have a few other pieces that use some
of the new server list technologies like
cloud run ok so tell us a little bit
more about how the app is built tested
and deployed oh yeah
so my team have been using Jenkins for
years we just stuck with what we knew we
carried on using the same tools ok all
right so basically you're using Jenkins
you've got Google compute engine that
sounds complicated configuration
authentication Oliver how do you make
that work well actually we use the
ansible plugin for Jenkins that's got
great support for GCP takes care of all
the authentication for us and it
actually even restarts a service at the
end when we deploy daily binary ok so
why don't you show it yeah I will show
you right now ok cool so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna speed up the process
on the backend to take advantage of all
that extra CPU and memory we get on
compute engine so this right here is the
main loop of our program I'm going to
change that to five times the speed
let's go big right here I'm going to
commit that change I am gonna push it up
to github that's where we store our code
and then I am gonna kick off a build in
Jenkins so that takes about 25 seconds
it's gonna copy down the source code
from github it's going to build our go
binary copy it across the compute engine
and then restart our service okay so I
should remember they should the workflow
that we used to use when the app was
running in a datacenter you know using
Jenkins and such like so just the actual
plug-in is anything that's different
yeah it's almost exactly the same and I
even use IntelliJ it's the same
front-end IDE that I used to use okay
and you plug a Mingo is that correct
yeah I absolutely love go I find
multi-threading so much easier than
Python and it has great support for a
lot of new cloud technologies - that's
great ok well it looks like it's
finished yeah I think I build this
finished and if you look up there it's
even faster
ok so dope is much much faster than it
was before so that's pretty cool
so Nick was able to migrate an existing
application to Google compute engine
that's why adding the answerable plug-in
to Jenkins but that's a care of all of
the boring config and makes our
deployments more reliable and secure so
thanks Nick
so move into the cloud not only allows
you to perform the kind of app
migrations that Nick is just so nice but
you can also take advantage of many
other new technologies including
kubernetes in fact customers using
kubernetes tell us that they're able to
go faster go from codes a reduction in
under 10 minutes it's not unusual to see
30 to 50 deployments a day the
kubernetes helps manage and scale your
micro service based apps but it's not
always easy there's a fair amount of
Plexus II they can get in the way of
this codon so that's why we're really
excited today to be announcing cloud
code an IDE add-on that makes it easy to
rapidly build debug and deploying to
matches apps directly from your IDE
giving you the local development
experience where you stay so so hey pre
are you've been working on our
kubernetes Fun Center and can you show
us what you're building and give us some
insight into the tools that you're using
to do the build for sure mandy so I've
been working on adding a new share
button to our game of life game now that
Nick has made the game so much faster I
think it'd be really cool if people
playing the game had a way to share it
with their friends so I've been working
on our API layer which lives in
kubernetes
and as a team we actually decided to
host the game in kubernetes because we
wanted it to scale really easily as more
and more people started to play and
luckily kubernetes does all of that hard
work for us
so I actually got started developing
this feature completely locally with
tools like mini cube I just started
writing some code in my IDE and I was
able to get the feature up and running
without even needing a network
connection which was really nice for me
so I'm at the point now where I feel
like the feature looks pretty good and I
want to deploy it to our staging
environment before I deploy to
production so I'm just gonna go ahead
and do that right now
so if I remove these comments that'll
add my new share button and then I can
deploy with clout code okay so wait you
just enter in your IDE and then build
the bargain run on Google compute engine
child code deploy is that all you have
to do that's all I had to do all I had
to do was hit the cloud code deploy
button and then cloud took over the rest
of the deployment deployment for me if
you take a look at the logs you can see
that cloud code rebuilt my images push
them to my registry and then redeploy my
application for me it's really nice
because it takes care of all of this
hard work for me and I can just keep on
writing code or do something else while
it does all of the hard work so it looks
like the application is deployed
successfully
so if we take a look at our staging
environment we can see the new share
button and if I just click on that all
right yeah it looks pretty good and I
think it's ready for production that's
perfect
did you see that so our team has been
working on cloud code for a long time
and we're for all to say that it's
available this week today maybe this
week most of you have heard about it
today already so there'll be a deep dive
on cloud codes in the DevOps spotlight
tomorrow and several breakout sessions
so big round the cloud code so thank you
so come along to that tomorrow DevOps
Priya what more can you show us so now
that we've deployed the Nuba into
staging I think it looks pretty good and
I want to deploy to production as well
and luckily deploying a production is
just as easy all I have to do is commit
these changes to github and as soon as
they're merged into master cloud bill
will pick up my new feature and then
deploy it to our production cluster and
we should be able to see the feature in
production in just a couple minutes okay
so just one thing before you do that now
that you've created the share button
when we're in production we're expecting
users to share the app with their
friends so how we can handle the
potential increasing traffic that might
come about the application goes viral
that's a really good point so we
actually have a dashboard that tracks
our gke cluster and looking at CPU usage
in the cluster right now it looks pretty
good but you're right a lot more people
might start playing the game hopefully
they do once we have our share button so
just to be safe I'm gonna increase the
number of pods in our cluster from one
to ten just that it can handle any
increased traffic and luckily this is a
really simple change in my deployment
yeah Mille I just have to up the number
of replicas from one to ten and it looks
like I've made a made a bit of a mistake
but it looks like cloud code also
doesn't yell validation which is really
nice so I guess I was expecting an
integer let me fix that and at this
point all I have to do is push these
changes to github and like I mentioned
earlier cloud build will pick up our new
feature and deploy it to production and
we should
however share button in just a minute or
two okay so with a single commit Priya
was able to scale the deployed app to
handle the increase load so Priya now
that were in production how do we tie
our front-end and back-end components of
the app together we need to make sure
that the app is whole team working as
intended right yeah so you may have
noticed that I was tracking our gke
cluster and stack driver earlier so our
entire team actually monitors all the
different pieces of our application with
stock driver and it's really nice
because stack driver integrates really
well with all the different CCP services
we use so you can see there's a
dashboard tracking our GCE VM which Nick
was just working on and I was looking at
the dashboard for a gke cluster it was
actually really easy for a team to set
this up I think Dan made the whole thing
in like 10 or 15 minutes okay so
stackdriver gives us a single pane of
glass for observing and monitoring
monitoring multiple metrics from the
same or from different apps and services
and here we're seeing metrics from both
Nick and Priya's parts of the app
combined into a single dashboard Nick
and pre are not just monitoring the app
on their own they're monitoring the app
the entire app as a team they want to
understand what's happening within the
app and how to use as a behalf of
responding to our changes together and
this is all completely automated it's
very very easy to create the dashboard
together as a team so thank you Priya
that was awesome so we've seen how we
migrate an existing back-end service for
the cloud we then built a brand new
scalable front-end with kubernetes and
cloud code I wonder now how we might
extend this application with some BOTS
or third-party integrations hey Mandy
let me show you a slack bot we've been
working on to interact with the game
board but with Google Cloud around hey
Stan the diners our he's the guy who
looks after our production services and
he also does will abound slack
integrations as well so what are you
working on that hey Matt yeah so i'm
actually right in the middle now of
adding a new feature to this chat bot
let me get this merged and deployed and
then i'll explain how it all works
so like Priya before I'll just save this
and commit this and put
left to github and cloud build will
automatically deploy it normally I would
have done a code review with someone on
the team for this but there are a few
thousand people watching today so I'll
skip that step so the app I built here
is a way to interact with the game board
inside of slack where you select to
communicate on our team and I wanted to
add some administrative and fun features
with the chat bot so I can do some
things here like clearing the game
warden Wells randomizing it to get some
state back on it to start out with the
feature that I just added is a way to
create some special shapes that the
users of the app don't have access to I
can create one of these here with this
command I can pick a couple shapes from
the menu here when I create a line I'll
enter some coordinates what's your
favorite color today man do you what do
you fake Deverell red awesome we can see
this appear on the board so I carry a
pager for my day job and I use Google
cloud run to deploy this application
he's the last thing I want to have to
worry about for a fun app like this is
having to configure monitoring scaling
yeah Moe and deployments so cloud run is
designed to run containers in a fully
managed environment which let me use the
language and tooling I was familiar with
to get started or in this case when I
just decided to try out for fun no js'
it provides a fully service experience
abstracting away configuration
monitoring scaling and deployments all
right yeah so cloud run lets me focus on
just the code best of all it's designed
to work seamlessly with cloud build all
I had to do here was submit my code to
github and cloud built automatically
packaged up my application and gets it
the point of running in cabrón all right
okay so that's fantastic
dan just added a completely new features
for docs nap very simply and very
quickly so well done let's hear if it
down everyone
[Applause]
okay so to summarize knickers Walters
through deploying a back-end component
of our application to a virtual machine
running on Google compute engine using
IntelliJ with Jenkins an unanswerable
plugin Priya then showed us how cloud
code helps her build test and deploy a
kubernetes component of our application
including a full local development
workflow Priya don't push the changes to
production using cloud build and we're
also able to monitor and observe all of
the app components in stackdriver then
was then able to add a nifty new feature
to the app using cloud run which allows
developers to run any stateless
containers in a service environment to
learn more about all of this please join
us at the DevOps spotlight tomorrow
morning
also check out our DevOps booth since
location and please please download
cloud code today so let's have one more
round of applause for Nik Priya and Dan
our demo team great job team
[Applause]
all right it's not all great now all
this development stuff has been great
but this is software you know things
sometimes fall apart
maybe we completely underestimated the
amount of traffic that a share button
will generate for our app so we need to
plan for that as well and we do that as
a team so to talk about sustainable
DevOps practices I want to bring out our
Johanna Lee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks Mandy I was having a great time
playing the game backstage Go Red Team
but I used to be a tester in my previous
life and it's kind of built into my DNA
to break stuff after all nothing goes as
smoothly as this demo has actually gone
in production it just doesn't happen so
let's bring out the wheel of misfortune
[Music]
today our incident causing wheel says
that the demo team on stage is going to
have to deal with some kind of network
error
so my friends backstage the gremlins are
going to cause some sort of network
error and we'll see what happens I'm
getting a bad feeling about this part ah
I would be too so the wheel of
misfortune is actually an educational
tool used internally at Google and it's
basically DMD or LARPing for developers
and operators tools like this are part
of our culture because we know that
incidents happen every application has
bugs or configuration issues that you
don't find until after you've deployed
to production and annoyingly
some of those bugs don't seem to show up
until it's late at night and it's your
turn to carry the pager which leads to
crazy stories that we tell each other
when we get together at events like this
like the time before Google that I was
restarting services in a parking lot of
a burger joint because that's where I
was when the pager went off incidents
happen they happen to everyone and
sometimes they even happen to our dev
team onstage
is that the pager are you I think so it
sounds like the wheel of misfortune took
down the app I'll do some debugging and
get back on it you get up at and I'll be
rooting for you so whether you're small
start-up or a big company you have
incidents even if you are absolutely
stellar your production practices some
stuff is just beyond your control
dependencies and operating systems
occasionally have critical security
updates and even when you test your code
thoroughly complex systems by definition
have complex integration and sometimes
you don't find those integration issues
until the code is live incidents are
gonna happen whatever we do and if we
don't want to have very many incidents
the only thing that I know to do is to
just not ever deploy anything and that
that is boring it leads to very very
boring applications so if incidents are
inevitable what can we do to make
weathering them if not fun at least less
stressful maybe and the only answers I
know to that or good tooling
solid practices and an absolutely great
team buy good tooling I mean having ways
to be quickly notified about incidents
and one place where you track and
coordinate all the folks involved in an
incident response significant incidents
can involve multiple teams from your
operators and developers trying to
figure out as a configuration issue is
it a code issue so your support and PR
teams trying to help your customers deal
with it and letting them know about any
workarounds you might have and keeping
track of all aspects of a response like
this in one place saves time because
you're not playing some crazy game of
telephone having to repeat current
status Denine two people in a row that
leaves you with much more time to
address the incident and the issue at
hand but incident management and
tracking is only one part of tooling to
address issues quickly most teams also
have things like crash reporting service
monitoring aggregated logging
performance profiling and each of you
probably has even more tools than that
to deal with stuff like this and of
course if you're using stackdriver you
also have things like live for
debugging which after several years at
Google still feels like it's slightly
magic to me um speaking of debugging
how's it going over there Dan
it looks like the wheel of misfortune
was right the little gremlins backstage
broke right network connection to Redis
I'm gonna do a failover to another
instance I'm glad that we had backups so
I'll give you a few more minutes to get
things sorted out earlier I mentioned
that solid practices are important too
when I stay solid practices I'm talking
about DevOps best practices like in the
like the lessons in the SR e books that
is things like setting in SLO to help
you understand the customer impact of an
event and having run books and
procedures for when the pager goes off
and practicing your response on a
regular basis a lot of folks I know they
set up their backups or their disaster
recovery but they never practice
actually going through the procedures
and restoring from backup and as the
common saying goes if you haven't
recently restored from your backups you
don't actually have backups at Google in
addition to things like the wheel of
misfortune
we have dirt dirt stands for disaster
recovery testing and what that means is
that on a regular basis a large section
of the company or multiple sections
sometimes practice dealing with
different scenarios and they're trying
to find the place this is that we're not
as resilient as we want to be and we
practice handling scenarios that
thankfully don't happen very often like
potentially a zombie apocalypse or
happen ever also potentially a zombie
apocalypse for me though the biggest
secret to making production incidents
less unfun is having a good team you
need a team that works together well a
team that practices blameless
post-mortems
and assumes that everyone is doing the
best they can with the information they
have available a team that knows that
when things go poorly it means that your
tooling your procedures or your
documentation need updating not that one
person messed up you need a team with a
variety of backgrounds and skills the
applications we work on have lots and
lots of moving parts lots and lots of
different kinds of storage or
programming languages and if you have a
team that knows
all of those things you'll find you'll
find the issues faster but most of all
you need a team that believes we
shouldn't have the same issue twice
because having the same issue twice is
boring and boring is not fun so I'm
gonna tell y'all secret despite the fact
that we think about incidences unfun for
me at least they're actually a weird
kind of fun I remember the first time
that I wrote an incident report years
and years and years ago and in that
moment I felt like I was finally finally
a real engineer there's a very distinct
kind of satisfaction that comes from
detecting an issue in production
debugging it rolling out a fix and then
verifying it after all when you fix an
issue you are helping your customers and
you're helping your team you're making
people have a better day and this
contradictory fun but also unfun nature
of incidents is why when we get together
big piles of text folks we talk about
that one day when everything went wrong
at my startup and or that one day that
someone at the data center hit the big
red button everything hmm we know that
these issues aren't supposed to be fun
we know that there aren't supposed to be
any heroes but these things are
interesting and part of the reason
they're interesting is that they happen
to all of us everyone can empathize with
stuff going wrong and since everyone can
empathize we can all learn from each
other I've learned a lot by reading
incidents reports from other companies
and everything I've learned from the
Google sres has changed how I think
about operations and if this whole
section sounds deeply unfun to you
that's fine too we all get to have
things we like and there are lots of
folks who just want to get on with
making technology do cool stuff and
that's the best part of using the cloud
you can choose which parts are fun with
you and if you're not into
infrastructure you can leave
infrastructure maintenance to other
people after all we're all here and
we're all in tech because we find using
technology to do cool stuff fun so let's
see if our development team is having
any fun with the wheel of misfortune
were you able to deal with this issue
with some of the best practices we just
talked about I think we need a new rule
if you haven't failed over to your
backup Rattus live on stage you haven't
failed over Yap should be back up Thanks
Congrats
very well done so next Adams gonna come
out and teach us about a bunch more cool
stuff
I was so awesome Oh awesome
it's great um so in the other keynotes
all of you heard from customers like
Scotiabank and Colgate and how they're
all using Google cloud but there's one
thing I know and then I know about
developers is that it you'd like to hear
from other developers and not just the
executives here their experiences so we
wanted to introduce you to some real
developers and we're lucky to have the
amazing Loren Buckman that's gonna
introduce us come on out Loren
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks Adam let's get right into it
please join me in welcoming our first
customer to the stage we've got yo ah've
and Lee Ron from Wix
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there welcome I'll or a nepeta beer
so for those of you in the audience who
are not as familiar with Wix they
provide tools and services to build
websites Wix has more than a hundred and
fifty million users and they serve two
billion API requests a day so can you
tell me about what you're working on now
Wix start off by letting anyone build
professional websites really efficiently
now we are working on a new product
we're weeks called Cove it and Cove it
lets developers build web applications
in a much more efficient way so why the
move to web applications we're expanding
into applications because consumer
expectations of websites are changing
things like dynamic content services
integrations real-time communications so
the line between a web app and a website
is blurring with tweaks you can set up
your website using the visual builder
now with corvid we let developers take
advantage of the same visual builder and
encoding capabilities giving them the
most productive way to build web
applications so how can Kroy would
empower Google Cloud developers so GCP
can empower the users of kovat in
different ways you can use in your
coffee duplication any of Google cloud
databases
spanner cloud sequel firestore you can
monitor all your application with stock
driver you can use any of Google api's
like pub/sub or any of the machine
learning api's almost all of your
favorite Google cloud products can be
used from a covert application so with
that you take all of the power of Google
cloud and without its surface into web
applications using kovat that you would
be much more effective and much more
productive sounds great but maybe we
could stop talking about it and see what
you're gonna do I hear you're gonna
build a chat but on stage for us sure so
as you know building a chat bot take
days if not weeks
today Lauren and I are going to show you
how to build a chatbot application in
just 60 seconds using corvid in dialogue
flow one of our early adopters of corvid
is a company called Elango and they are
connecting both owners with people who
want to rent a boat for vacation we're
going to use their application as the
example sounds pretty cool let's switch
over to the demo now sure so what is he
now is the boat search page Leon let's
connect Wix chat with dialog flow sir to
do that Leon is switching to an ID and
is created a new file an event such as
file in the kovat project back-end which
runs on OGS in the file is adding an
event for the chat on message that is
triggered anytime there is a new message
in the chat so you're adding the
integration into a dialogue flow now
yeah sure so now with rest of the code
you integrate into the dialog flow so
now anytime someone writes anything in
the chat we get a message send it to
dialog flow we get back the response and
write it back into the chat next we
train dialogue flow to detect the best
deal and filter intense and we want to
create user experience Neron is
switching to another file the search
page code and is that in another on
message event this one runs in the
client on the browser letting us update
the filters of the page or open a
lightbox for best deal the only thing
left for us to do is to deploy the
application we call it publish and so
let's switch back to the visual builder
and just before we publish the
application
this is the visual builder that makes
Cove it so much more powerful giving you
all of the visual elements you need to
build a modern web application and you
can actually see your code here as well
so can I use any idea with this you can
use any ID you can actually write code
years well and by clicking on publish
button you get your application
available
to everyone globally cross cloud cross
region and let's let's go and try it out
yep
so imagine you have a customer who wants
to go and find a boat trip to the
Bahamas so we write that into the chat
and the message is sent to dialogue flow
dialogue flow detects what is there and
it's going to ask us for more
information when do we want to go for
vacation so let's try this Samuel again
it is sent to dialogue flow it will
detect the filter intent and we'll get
back the result we're updating the
filter on the page the location and the
dates we're updating the search so the
old page is been updated and we got a
result although it looks a little bit
pricey so let's try and search for the
best deal so writing load let's try the
best deal what can you offer me it is
sent to dialogue flow it detects the
best deal in 10 we get back the result
we have an algorithm to figure out what
is the best deal and we show that in
lightbox
in that looks where is more reasonable
that is so this is so cold what we just
saw is so much better than the typical
chat window I mean it's usually separate
from like the actual web app but this
actually brought up dynamic content
within the app itself
um how else can developers use corvid so
developers can use Covell to build any
kind of data or logic rich web
applications kovat technical previous
available today and the full version
will be rolled out later this Samuel go
and check it out wix.com slash corvid
thank you thank you
thanks yellow and leer on next I'd like
to welcome on stage Kyle and Shay
cofounders of Arctic
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us so I hear you've
been up to some really interesting stuff
over the last couple of days regarding
the new release of anthos you guys are a
premier google services partner and
you've been a design partner with us on
GK in G ke on Prem and the recently
released Anthes can you tell us a little
bit about what you've been talking about
the projects you've been working on yeah
thanks for having us first of all it's
excited to be here our main focus is
working with customers to embrace
automation micro services and all things
kubernetes along the way trying to make
everyone's job a little bit more fun and
I hear you have a demo of an anthos use
case for us can you set that up yeah we
do I'll tee it up for you so let's face
it we're all developers in the room and
developers want to write code release at
a high velocity operations and security
though want stability and they want to
reduce change these call these goals are
sometimes at odds but can be solved with
policy driven automation leveraging GCP
services including config management so
let's kick it over to Shea and show off
some of the cool things he's been
working on over to you Shea well maybe
we should really start with what my
challenge is most the time as a
developer my automated builds are just
too slow and really the issue with that
is that I don't have enough scalable
infrastructure on my own from site so
what I really want is cloud however my
platform and Ops teams they just they
just have too many rules and I can't
really fit into them so really as a
developer I don't want to know about
kubernetes I don't want to know how to
configure and I don't want to deal with
on Prem infrastructure so really what
we've done is we built this environment
to show how anthos config management can
ease the pain in this environment I get
my own ephemeral kubernetes clusters
we've already cut over to the demo which
is apparently where we are and inside of
each one of those clusters we're pulling
from a base config which is my single
source of truth and that's controlled by
my operations team and my security team
so I don't have to know anything about
that so really what I want to do is I
just want to commit my code and then see
it come up on the other side
and so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna make a minor modification to our
application here
super simple I'm gonna change my
background you don't usually use the
editor online right I do not know this
is all web browser-based huh we're gonna
commit our change now what that's gonna
do for me is that's gonna kick off an
automated pipeline that's gonna go
through Jenkins I can't show it to you
right now because frankly the password
was not saved in the demo and it showed
up there and so I'm kind of logged out
and I don't have it but that's okay
because what I can do
this happens in live demos guys let's be
honest what I can do if you haven't seen
Jenkins before
nice if you haven't seen Jenkins before
I mean this is just you know this is
just the window here but that's fine
it's gonna build us a pipeline that's
actually gonna build a new set of GK
infrastructure for us it's gonna go
ahead and test that infrastructure for
us and then wait to deploy into my
on-premise environment but the core here
is that I don't want to know much about
the kubernetes side here so in here I've
got my nice little app we're gonna take
a look at Toronto it's nice and cold in
Toronto you see the nice cold background
and what should happen when we finish
this off or if I was able to execute my
pipeline it would change to a very nice
different background but what I want to
show you and what's most important is
that in side of the kubernetes console
I've got a series of ephemeral clusters
so these clusters they're gonna go away
when I'm done I don't need to know
anything about them I haven't had to
configure them they were just given to
me by my ops team through my pipeline
but if I jump a little bit deeper I can
go ahead and take a look at my actual
apps or my workloads I did not configure
any namespace I haven't configured any
services or anything else I just
configured my docker file and that was
it and modified my coat what you can see
here is a separation between my prod
namespace and which is in my core
on-prem and my test namespace which gets
applied to every ephemeral cluster that
I built this is the core piece that's
really important for me now for those of
you who know what this looks like in the
kubernetes world we have a series of
llamo files that I would typically have
to build
I didn't have to build this this is
coming from a single repository single
source of truth it gets deployed in
every cluster that comes up for me all I
really cared about was actually my cube
CTL can manage do one patch
I just patch into play the update but
this is in the pipeline given to me by
ops again all I did was actually change
the background of my application and had
I been able to log into Jenkins I would
have actually shown you the actual
background as well but I can't so I'm
gonna kick it back over to you Kyle yeah
thanks Jay
so they talked a little bit about dr
earlier we also planned for the worst so
che posted a blog up on our site it's up
there now so if you do want to dive in a
little bit deeper you can certainly do
that so go check it out good job Shay so
it's one thing to have a use case demo
but can you talk a little bit about the
value customers are getting from all of
this
sure well I think everybody knows in
here it's no secret that private cloud
never really delivered to development
teams as far as automation capabilities
and what they really needed the
developers we work with they're looking
for a common experience across UCP and a
private cloud and what they've been
experienced in today is a different
experience than what they get in GCP
then in our own Prem environments not to
mention operating custom kubernetes
environment at scales has its fair share
of challenges so anthos is here to
address that starting with g:k on Prem
and config management and we've been
excited to be working on it there's a
great description of what this does for
the organization but for the individual
developers and the audience here what
should they care about most similar to
what I said before extending GK into
your data center delivers the value of
cloud provides flexibility and choice
for deployment it's just another
deployment target just another region
and extending a common toolkit across
both lets us move faster with more
reliability and security almost like a
white flag for DevOps
I think so and the best part about it
all know kubernetes experience acquired
alright thank you so much for joining us
and with for all of your help as a
design partner thanks good to be here
joining us next on stage is twinkled is
I VP of technology for Kohl's come on
out twinkle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the coals is a retail giant with
thousands of stores hundreds of
thousands of associates millions of
online customers and billions in sales
hey twinkle thank you for having me
Lauren so you started out your you are a
VP of Technology today but you started
off as a developer I hear you used to be
a UNIX system that's right Roland I
started as a system administrator but
before we go there I would like to take
this opportunity to give a shout-out to
my women in technology as you can see
I'm gonna be a mother of two and I still
continue my passion in corporate world
which is highly demanding and have high
pressure I still continue to enjoy being
on my production calls so if I can do it
you all can too I never thought I'd get
to say this at an enterprise tech
conference but Yas Queen okay so tell us
about how you moved into your leadership
role during my days as a system
administrator I spent a lot of time
gathering requirements procuring
environment propagating code and my
least favorite part was the ticketing
process it slowed down the entire
delivery pipeline so I came up with a
thought process of automating the entire
pipeline with a click of a button which
would reduce the overhead of operations
and speed up the delivery process my
manager loved it and that was my first
gig as a leader today at Kohl's we have
200 plus developers NS Ari's working
together on store and digital strategy
to give the seamless customer experience
which is our goal we are running
hundreds of micro services and thousands
of containers on Google gke
and we have delivered
successful holidays so is anyone here in
the audience who's an SRE or manages s
re can raise your hands okay so do you
have any tips on how to make those teams
happy it's a very high-pressure
environment so as a manager it is very
important to know that we support our
team and give them what they need to
deliver we need to make sure they are
engaged and they're supported at Kohl's
we have lot of hackathon schedules and I
have personally worked with my
leadership team to invest in training
and tech conferences so what did you
learn from your team about what they
needed to be more effective at work the
hackathon was a lot of fun we learned
what developers needed innovation
freedom no ops we knew we had to build
our developer experience so you come up
with this happy developer checklist and
then you set out to implement it across
your org
can you talk a little bit more about
some of those specific fixes sure so um
so we got this checklist the first thing
we did was to break a monolithic code
into micro services because that gave
freedom to the developers to choose the
framework and the language they would
desire to code today we are using
angularjs node.js and Java spring would
also as a developer I don't want to
worry about operations so my team came
up with a solution where we can deploy
the environment propagate the code and
in do the integration testing we use
language like Python and golang to build
the solution also we integrated some of
the great GK features like sto fault
injection and circuit breaker it's all
one-click itself so and fully automated
it's great that you've been focused on
helping your developer stay productive
and happy but for the managers of dev
teams in the audience do you have any
final tips for them and their teams
throughout my journey I learned a lot I
had
leaders and team to support me along the
way as a manager it is very important to
know your team so my mantra for a happy
team would be simple solution for
complex problems complement technology
with innovators and find the right
balance between work and fun I think we
can learn a lot about finding balance
from you thank you so much for joining
us today this was great thank you for
having me all right so we've been
hearing for some from customers ready
for some Googlers we've got a demo derby
for you coming up Greg come on out and
get us started
[Music]
thanks Lauren so I have to tell you all
next is my absolute favorite time of the
year
in fact I'm such a nerd about it you
probably can tell I'm actually wearing
some custom Google theme next sneakers
at the moment I know right
but if next is my favorite time of year
this next block is the keynote is my
favorite part of next that's because
we're gonna spend some quality time with
some Google engineers and we're gonna
walk you through some live demos and
technical drill downs of some of our
favorite parts of Google cloud but you
didn't come here to sit to hear me talk
you came to see the demos so let's get
started and please welcome up my demo
all-star team Emma
Eric Philippe and staring come on up
folks
[Applause]
hard to upstage a man in a cape uh let's
get started
you know it's not often that I get an
opportunity to be on stage with someone
who broke a world record but you heard
but as you heard yesterday from sundar
back on March 14th we announced that
Emma had done just that she'd set the
world record for the most precise
calculation of pi ever and there's a lot
we can learn about that about building
infrastructure and applications
so please welcome Emma up and we're
gonna walk through exactly how she did
it
Emma come on up so I mean a world record
holder that's pretty cool can you tell
me exactly how many digits you
calculated sure it's funny watch video
415 billion 926 medium 500 5000 897
digits so that that probably looks a
little familiar to some of you right
that number it's sure that it's damn PI
to be on digits
I know very googley right so maybe can
we run that calculation now on the stage
yeah I'd love to you about the entire
calculation to take four months which I
believe a bit too long for live demo so
I know you like demos but I think four
months is probably pushing it a bit weed
between between you and Gwen Stefani so
how about maybe a smaller number sure
how about five billion digits five
billion is the small version that you're
gonna do right now in the demo all right
go for it
sure so here's the machine we are going
to use for the demo it uses the latest
interpret cascade Lake architecture
which is about available alpha it has 60
V CPUs that can run at 3.8 gigahertz and
it has 240 gigabytes of memory now I'm
gonna run program called Y cruncher
that's the same program we use for while
recording now I'm gonna do everything in
memory here the rest of it is we can
calculate in memory and I'm gonna choose
five billion now it's
so while that starts backstage Emma you
had told me that before you did this it
was generally thought to be impossible
to use cloud to break a world record can
you sort of explain why that was sure
because we needed a lot of storage and a
very high net-worth repute
why crunch ah is one of the most
efficient public available software to
calculate pi and it is designed for one
large computer with a lot of storage and
we need 170 terabytes 170 terabytes of
storage that's that's a fair bit of
storage and I think you have a picture
right of what one of the previous
systems look like so here the pictures
of computer they use for the record in
2013 and you can see from the picture
folks this is exactly what we were
describing it's basically a great big
computer connected to a shedload of
disks but GCP has sort of two unique
advantages in terms of cloud one is you
can attach very large disks per VM 64
terabytes per VM so that helps and the
other is we have a lot of fault
tolerance and resilient built it into
the disk system and the network right
but even then everyone I talked to said
I'd be blocked on network throughput so
I run some experiments I estimate the
amount of data we read and write did the
math to figure out how much bandwidth we
needed and it seemed possible to finish
it in four to five months so four to
five months we've gotten it down to at
least it seems feasible so I think you
have the architecture right yep so to
optimize this disk stupid I use this
architecture here there is one load
running the program with 96 PC peers and
1.4 terabytes of memory and there are 24
additionals
hosting the storage and providing bond
wheels with this configuration I so 20k
bits per second throughput for reads and
16 gigabits per second for writes if you
are interested in learning more about
the technical details
I never took up this next with Alexander
II the developer why cruncher and the
video will be available on YouTube now
there's something
interesting in about this architecture I
want you to notice usually we think of
scale up or scale out as being two
different approaches but Emma's actually
doing both the core machine is scale up
it's a very large VM with a lot of V
CPUs and a lot of RAM but the storage is
a classic scale out using many nodes and
the network to basically get incredibly
high throughput so the skill is one
challenge and the other challenge was
reliability I can imagine because
remember that architecture there's one
node that's actually doing all the math
if something goes wrong there you're
really in trouble right yep the limiting
factor on scaling pike location is a
reliability of the components such as
disk and memory and every part in this
architecture is a single point of
failure even a single bit failure
anywhere during an operation would
invalidate the entire computation and so
how long was the actual calculation
period we run the program for one
hundred and eleven point eight days or
if we count all the 24 months
twenty-five machines it's seven point
six machine years seven point six
machine years I don't know how you do
the math that's a lot of uptime yep and
because computer engine suppose live
migrations we were able to confidently
run these machines from four months
without any unexpected shutdowns or
reboots and you doing this in the cloud
also had a personal benefit right yep
but for me it was great that I could
move from Tokyo to Seattle while the
Caucasian Lonnie and I didn't have to
move the physical machines from Japan
today yes yeah try to get that through
TSA
[Applause]
so I want to ask our rest of our demo
panel here what do we think being able
to run a VM for 111 days without a
reboot fun part or not fun part what's
the really fun part oh and let me show
you how about fasting so I'm an engineer
which means I don't trust anything no
matter how we love our system is I
always want backups
right so here's the actual disk fees for
the calculation and I wrote a simple
script with a g-cloud command to take
snapshots of these persistent disks I'm
gonna run this B script right now and
with this 1g clock man it's working in
the background I was able to take
snapshots and backups would of 240
terabytes of disks in less than 15
minutes and it happened without any
visible performance impact so again
think about that 240 terabytes of
backups in 15 minutes with no impact in
performance so when we started yeah
absolutely
[Applause]
when we started you kicked off a
calculation of Pi are we still
calculating PI yep actually we just
finished it tooks 97 seconds to
calculate 5 billion digits and this is
actually for pointing up 7 gigabytes of
text file let's let's take a look inside
I'm gonna cut the file yep well here the
result this is pi thanks very much Emma
thank you
[Applause]
now I'm gonna go on a limb here and
guess that most of you don't have a
critical business need to calculate 30
trillion digits of pi but I'll bet some
of you do have workloads where somebody
has said we can't do that in cloud we
need too many big VMs we need too much
uptime I've got old software that can
only scale up and I have yet to meet a
developer who says they like their
machines to go down so that's a quick
example of Google infrastructure being
able to power not just an interesting
calculation but really something
breaking the world record so let's move
up the stack we did infrastructure let's
move up the stack to data let's face it
we're all digital pakrats I don't know
when the last time is I deleted a photo
or an email I just assume I can store it
forever and you know what our companies
are exactly the same so now the problem
is how do I actually make any sense out
of all that data how I do I find meaning
and all that noise and typically that's
where the pain comes in if there's one
thing I know it's that managing sharding
scaling and patching large-scale
databases is definitely not the fun part
but luckily we've got this almost
magical tool called bigquery so to talk
about bigquery and have some fun with it
let me bring up our own Captain bigquery
Felipe Hoffa everyone a Felipe
so Felipe we're used to seeing and
reading how about big data is really
targeting some of the big questions that
we face as a species is there life on
other planets what's the nature of the
human genome do developers want tabs or
spaces why don't you just pick one of
those at random and solve for us hey
hello everyone how you doing let's come
yes
let's have some fun with data break
let's analyze data and let's answer some
questions that are important for
developers so how about taps versus
places I think you picked a good one can
I get a process for taps team tabs I'm
hoping you do something a little more
scientific than just a clap contest okay
let's use data okay so we have this
public data sets program that has a lot
of data sets ready for you to be queried
we have hundreds of these data sets here
ready for you you can see the whole
catalog in the console and today it runs
for this question I'm going to use the
copy of github that we have we have
files that we took out of github all of
the open source files and we have them
inside bigquery so we can run queries
over them if you have never used big
query it also has a web UI so if anyone
can just jump right now right into the
web UI and start running queries and in
this case I have this table that has two
terabytes of source code and more than
250 million files and I'm going to
extract from it all of the files I'm
interested in like I'm going to look at
this question language my language and
once I have extracted all of these files
I can write a query like this
let me start running it right now okay
so while this query runs I want to pause
for a second and point out a couple
things first of all big trees already
incredibly easy to use you just write
queries but in this case he didn't have
to upload the data because the public
data set program made it available the
second thing I want to think about is I
mean I want to go to the team here and
ask what do we think having to set up a
whole bunch of indexes just to get good
query performance fun part or not fun
part not funny
[Music]
the last thing I want to point out is
think about what Felipe is doing he's
writing a sequel query that analyzes
source code most of us think of sequel
for structured data financial records
business transactions I've seen a lot of
developer source code in my life and a
lot of it is not exactly what I'd call
structured and so but he's using sequel
to actually analyze that exactly like we
don't need in the first year we yes can
start writing sequel queries and in this
case I have a sequel query that is going
file by file it's splitting these files
in lines it's looking at the first
character if it's a space or a tab and
then we're telling up our numbers and
whatever our numbers let me visualize it
I have it here so it turns out that
generally people like Ted like spaces
you Java folks you're a little unsure
and man I don't want to put a space in
one of your gopher files like you are
really team tabs yeah oh that was
analyzing a bit about source code what
else can you learn about developers by
using bigquery sure so if little spaces
the most important question for
developers probably not can we somehow
measure what's the most important
question where do you all go when you're
lost where do you look for info when you
need help
Stack Overflow and we have a copy of
Stack Overflow inside the query tool so
now we can analyze it we can look for
the top questions just by the number of
views or we can do something a little
more special and we can look at the top
questions right now like in this case I
have a snapshot of 17 million questions
and I'm going to compare this snapshot
with the previous snapshot to know what
were the top questions only during this
quarter let me run the query so while it
runs any guesses on what's the most
commonly asked question I heard how to
exit vim down here somewhere what what
is the top question Felipe ok I got
myself here and we
more than 400,000 views this last
quarter is how do I undo the most recent
amazing yet yes that's regret and we've
all felt
we've all had regret yeah so so far we
figured out that most people like spaces
except Gophers who are delightfully
different and that everybody has a
moment of regret of having to back out
of a code change but big craze a product
for developers so can you get more
specific and find out about bigquery
developers let's go deeper let's use
bigquery to query Stack Overflow to see
what people are asking about the query
that's an inception moment but I'm gonna
trust you it's basically the same query
that I just had but now I'm filtering
here for only questions that we'd be
query and oh I have the many answers
here and you can see that the top
question for bigquery this last quarter
was Google bigquery delete rows and can
it be query can now delete rows now it
can yes we use data to listen to you yes
so what you saw was bigquery engineers
using bigquery to improve bigquery now
of course Stack Overflow isn't just
about asking questions it's about
answering questions what can you tell us
about that yes so let's see let's see
the answers part who is answering the
bigquery questions so now I can look at
the answers I will run a join it's a
little longer query to join it to see
questions type with the query find who
answer them and then find who got the
most votes this quarter and the results
let me analyze all of these questions
ran this large join eyes I'm there well
I hope you're there yes but what's
really really interesting for me and I
love this is everyone here involved they
are not Googlers they are just experts
that love the community they love
sharing what they know they love
answering questions and they are my real
heroes
Thank You me hey Gordon welcome William
Banting pand I'm Bobby luck thanks
Philippe Philippe may wear the Cape but
you all went to the questions of the
real heroes so we've seen how bigquery
is kind of the ultimate server list data
analytics platform but there's another
kind of server list isn't their server
list compute and here at next we've
announced cloud run bringing serverless
to containers and again we thought let's
do a deep demo and actually show you
cloud run in action so to do that please
welcome staring up and Ryan's Darrin and
Ryan come on up
[Applause]
hi we as developers we love stubbornness
we love that we can focus on our code
deploy and let the platform take care of
the rest
but you know developers keep asking us
hmm can we run most things several s
what about going beyond simple functions
introducing cloud run cloud run is a
brand-new product that allows you to run
any stateless HTTP container on
surveillance and it's available today
you know what let's see how easy it is
to run a container on cloud run so from
the cloud console
Ryan simply navigates to cloud run opens
the deployment page paste the URL of a
container image and clicks create that's
its data types clicking the mouse is the
hardest part of a demo folks just so you
know that's all we needed to deploy a
container to cloud run no infrastructure
to provision in advance
no yellow file and no service
so cloud run has imported on our image
made sure that it started and gave us a
stable and secure HTTP endpoints
so what we just deployed pretty cool
thank you so what we just deployed is a
scalable micro service that transforms
Microsoft Word documents into PDFs
let's see it in action let's give it a
doc to convert upload converting and we
get a PDF back so what is very
interesting here is that we are only
paying for when we use it that means
that when all micro service is not
processing any document well we just
don't pay anything so that's really cool
but I think would be interesting for
people to see how you actually
implemented the service so how did you
actually do the doc to PDF easy we
looked around and decided to add
OpenOffice to a container image now now
wait a second OpenOffice it's not
exactly a modern piece of software it's
about a 15 year old binary it's about
200 Meg's and you're saying you just
took that binary and deployed it into a
server list workload with cloud run yep
cloud run suppose docker containers that
means you can run any programming
language you want or any software in a
civilus way well let's look at the code
then exactly let's take a look at the
code so here what we have is a small bit
of Python code that listens for incoming
HTTP requests and then calls OpenOffice
to convert or container or period or
documents we also have a very small file
named Doug a file and don't be scared if
you are not familiar with this it's very
simple it start by defining our base
image in our case is the official Python
base image later we install open office
and we specify our start command then we
package all of this into a container
image using cloud build and deployed it
to cloud run on cloud run our micro
service
can automatically be scaled to thousands
of container instances in just a few
seconds if needed them and as I said we
only pay for the exact resources that we
use I'm gonna go to the judges one more
time on this so taking a legacy app
being able to bring it in them into a
micro-services environment and deploy it
with no code change in a server list is
that fun or not fun fun but wait wait we
are not done yet developers love civilus
but sometimes you might want to have a
little bit more control for example you
want bigger CPU sizes you want access to
GPUs you want more memory or maybe just
your corporate IT wants you to run in a
kubernetes engine cluster that's why we
are also introducing cloud run on gke
let's take a look using the exact same
user interface Ryan is going to deploy
the exact same container image this time
in our kubernetes and gene cluster and
instead of a fully managed region Ryan
is now picking our gke cluster we get
the same cloud run developer experience
its deploying and all microservice is
creating as before we get a stable
insecured endpoint that automatically
scales Oh micro service that's cost air
that you don't yet know there is more
all right well going so behind the
scenes cloud run and chlorin on gke are
powered by K native and open source
project to run several s workloads that
we launched last year this means we can
actually deploy the exact same micro
service to any kubernetes cluster
running K native let's take a look to do
this Ryan exports all micro service into
a file
then using the clip control command is
going to deploy it to manage K native on
IBM cloud and like before this is
creating the exact same micro-service or
to scale and giving us an endpoint to
invoke it we have it on IBM cloud this
portability is enabled by K native
that's awesome thanks Darren thanks Ryan
so cloud run gives you everything you
love about serverless there's no servers
to manage as a developer you get to stay
in the code which is kind of where you
want to be fast scale up even more
importantly scale down to zero you
literally pay nothing when there's no
cycles being run and it lets you do that
using any binary or language because
it's built on the flexibility of
containers you get a consistent
experience wherever you want it and that
can be on our fully managed environment
or on gke this is in beta today you can
all go and try it now so please I
encourage you to do that
so let's come back to that theme of data
but let's shift the focus just a little
bit some of you heard yesterday the work
that we did with student developers in
the NCAA around March Madness analysis
but in case you didn't we have a quick
little series of video snippets that we
put together around the program so let's
go ahead and run those Google cloud and
the n-c-double-a have teamed up to find
new ways to measure
[Applause]
[Music]
this March Madness see how Google cloud
student developers are using data to
analyze games all tournament long
[Music]
when student developer asana isn't
mixing data science with college
basketball he's mixing something like
this see how Google cloud is being used
to analyze March Madness student
developer bellezza enjoys executing
complex sequel deploying logistic
regression models and knitting that's
true
CEO Google Cloud is being used to
analyze March Madness you know it was a
real pleasure to work with that next
generation of software developers and
we're really excited they've been here
at next with us so please give us one
more round of applause for these student
developers have done such amazing work
[Applause]
so let's take the idea of sports and
data and let's turn it up to 11 and to
do that let me bring up Eric Schmidt one
of our developer advocates and a pretty
special customer poubelle Sidhu the
director of analytics and basketball
innovation for the Golden State Warriors
come on up Eric in feybelle
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow feybelle thanks for being here today
and congratulations on making the
playoffs you are in contention for your
third consecutive World Championship
thanks Eric I'm a huge fan of all things
Google so thanks for having me you bet
and I'm a huge fan of the Warriors now
getting to the playoffs isn't easy
winning championships isn't easy and I
know data science is a really really big
part of the equation for this success of
the Warriors can you talk a little bit
about how much data you have to manage
and also share some light on how much
data is generated in an NBA game I'm
sure most of the folks in the audience
maybe doesn't have an understanding of
that yeah absolutely so we know on the
court we have two teams five players
each two baskets and one ball what you
probably didn't know is that we have
tracking cameras in place that are
capturing player and ball movement we're
looking at every single dribble every
single pass every single catch and shoot
every single dive to the basket and by
the time the game is over we've
collected over 1 million events for the
game now if you do the math on that
that's 82 regular season games 30 NBA
teams so we're looking at big data and
it's my job to take this raw data and
make it actionable so I could provide
key insights to our coaches players
front office and ownership group well
you and I have been working on your
migration to the cloud over the past
couple weeks and one of the things I
found interesting is that since the NBA
provides the same data so all the teams
how do you end up competing that's a
good question we realized our biggest
advantage would be creative analysis and
unique insights craft around our
philosophies but in order to do so we
needed all of our data in our own cloud
environment great so let's talk data now
inside of the cloud show over here I've
pulled up some some of our sample raw
data in our cloud storage data lake and
what do we see here on the screen yeah
this is a raw vent file showing what
happened in the court and the players
involved it's super powerful information
we're talking tens and thousands of
files across
seven different schemas and how much
data are we talking in aggregate raaah
close to a terabyte Wow so how did you
manage all of this data like we're gonna
get to analysis here in a minute but
before you get to analysis you have to
solve the management problem yeah well
it was really hard we use lots of manual
scripts and only Paul the the data that
we thought we needed you know what we
never really had the full picture got it
so I've been keeping score here a little
bit no pun intended
you've talked about siloed data you've
talked about high fidelity data you've
talked about time series data at high
volume it's all very powerful if you can
get your hands on it I hate to break it
to you and don't take this personally
but you look and sound like a classic
enterprise you know in many ways we are
like any other and any other enterprise
except we skip bigger trophies but but
you know what we deal with the classic
8020 problem or we spend eighty percent
of our time
wrangling the data which only allows
this 20% of time to analyze the data all
right so you and I we've been working on
your migration to the Google cloud so
let's take a look at your new service
data analytics environment we're gonna
do a little bit of analysis to attack
some problems in the playoffs and we'll
try to flip this 8020 problem around now
I'm gonna pull up the cloud dataflow
console now before we could get to cloud
dataflow we had to do a couple of things
one we had to work on data movement so
for that we use the clouds storage
transfer service which provides an
automated way to migrate all of the data
in s3 where it's sitting raw over to
cloud storage so we've solved that
problem then we use cloud Composer to
automate all of our ETL processes inside
of dataflow now for my fellow data
engineers out there your ETL processes
probably look at things like orders and
line items and genomes and clickstream
data for the Warriors we're looking at
events all right it's all about the
event data so in dataflow
as you can see here we express a series
of transformations so the first one is I
go ahead and read I'll go ahead and read
not one file but hundreds of thousands
of files from DCs and then apply apply
additional transforms to parse and then
load that JSON in this case to over 35
different schemas so the beauty here is
that there's no more manual scripts
involved right so we're gonna spend less
time on management and more time out
analysis yeah so with our data warehouse
in place which is the output of these
final transforms we're gonna jump over
to bigquery and start looking at some
data so feybelle what do we see here
love this part right where we have here
is we have a distinct tables looking for
each logical event type in a game we're
looking at passes we're looking at picks
we're looking at gerbils we have four
point six two gigs up dribbles that's a
lot of dribbles yeah in fact we actually
now have four point six three because
whatever we up we just updated the
database this morning from games last
night so it's a lot of dribble now the
fun part is once we have all of our data
actionable we can start writing some
queries so I've written a quick query to
analyze how many times Steph Curry has
dribbled the ball this season
hey Philippe by the way dribbles the vs.
passes is the tabs versus spaces of
basketball but so there you go all right
so let's go ahead and run this query
Skan Skan Skan and there you go we just
scanned 608 Meg's of data in point 8
seconds the Bell Steph Curry has
dribbled the ball
18700 10 times that's pretty awesome
that's cute Eric and something you share
with your friends at Google ok but it's
not gonna help you with any
championships why not what do you need
man I need some more meaningful analysis
and also need the ability to look it up
without using sequel queries you mean
every warrior isn't writing sequel not
that I know of but I wouldn't put it
past death you're talking about stuff
Gary yeah that guy can shoot the ball
shoot the three can write sequel and I'm
pretty sure by now he probably has
anthos running on his mobile phone or
something like that so I
right so I'll be the first of it that
yeah bigquery can be kind of a lonely
place you know for data you're basically
querying you're looking information we
need to bring this data to life and
bigquery has amazing integration with
different visualization tools like look
or tableau in this case we're gonna go
ahead and use data studio so if I click
on this button I can jump over into a
visualization now for the sake of the
demo we fast forward a little bit it
took us about six seven minutes to put
this visualization together and I have
access to all of that data inside of
bigquery another thing to point out is
that for the sake of competitiveness to
help protect competitiveness as we get
into the playoffs all this data is real
except we've masked out a couple of the
teams that we think you're going to play
so congratulations you're gonna play
what I believe to be one of the greatest
NBA teams of all time
may they rest in peace the Seattle
SuperSonics yes my hometown team it's
always exciting to go back home but it's
right here what we're looking at is a
team profile page to see how SuperSonics
what merely immediately stands out is
how efficient they are in offense ranked
sixth overall but the two things that
really pop out to me is one they're
number one in the EM being transition
offense and also their bottom of the
league in half-court offense thirtieth
dead last dead last that's it so you
just looked at this report you start
ripping off a bunch of information this
is what you do every day like you can
glean insights like this once data comes
live and then you end up having to
collaborate and share this with your
teammates and coaches how have you
typically share this information in the
past well we share a lots of screenshots
they have one-off documents death by
PDFs that death by PDF maybe the worst
thing I've heard all day so all right so
let's go ahead and solve that problem
inside of data studio it's really really
easy to share information so I'm going
to go in and say it share this report
and we'll type in coach Steve and we'll
paste in a message and need a look into
transition-- office pretty cool I'm
gonna go ahead and send this is going to
end up in his inbox our ETL processes
are running B queries up-to-date booking
comes in he can see exactly what's going
on problem solved
Eric that's not cool
what why you sit him a problem but no
solution this is true it's okay though
okay so what we know what the Sonics is
that they have the number one transition
offense that's good to know but what I'm
interested in seeing is which players
specifically which trio of players make
up their biggest strengths got it so
we're gonna start kind of drilling into
this problem from a data science
perspective here we had some high-level
descriptive information kind of looking
at the what's yes we kind of see where
the you're gonna have potentially some
challenges with the Sonics so to dive
into our data science environment we're
gonna get out of visualizations and
we're gonna get into an I Python
environment and to do that we will use
AI platform notebooks which provides a
managed environment for Jupiter so once
I go ahead and deploy one of these
Jupiter labs I no longer have to do any
installation locally I'm done so I have
this fully managed running in the cloud
if I say click and open open in Jupiter
lab here's the notebook that you and I
and some of the folks in my team have
been working on for the past couple of
days now at the top we'll go ahead and
layer in a couple of the traditional
libraries that we feel good about things
like pandas the numpy and Matt plot we
also add a reference to be query so
inside of this notebook we have access
to all of the queries and views that we
previously built so in this case we put
the query I put put a query together to
unidentified which three-man combo is
the most dangerous on the Sonics let's
go ahead and run that it's gonna go out
it's a big query and there's the answer
to the question Shawn Kemp Gary Payton
and Detlef Schrempf problem solved we're
getting there but not quite that's a
great tree all right they're very
efficient but what I'm interested see
now is that what makes them so efficient
got it so we want to get deeper into the
kind of how and for that we need to do
deeper analysis in this case I took the
output from the previous cell and we've
done a couple of things one we're laying
it we're layering in some additional
sequel Felipe I hope you like this this
query is 500
eight lines long it does multiple joins
it uses most most of the analytical
functions etc we also have some Python
code that will go ahead and fuse
together to do a little bit more of
statistical analysis let's run this and
see if we can answer the question what
makes these guys so threatening so the
output of that is two rows so I'm
looking at the trio 38 different metrics
compared to the team and all of their
average metrics now this data is a
little intractable right this is not
gonna help us out in visuals next thing
we're going to do is pipe this data
frame through a little bit more pandas
code and build a visual let's see what
this looks like
alright feybelle what do we see here
about the Sonics okay now this is fun I
like this what we have here is the
difference between the trio and the team
average across a bunch of stats let's
take a look at the red bar on the right
in transition so we know the Sonics have
the number one transition offense and
this trio is right around the average
slightly better so I need to make sure
not emphasize to our coaching staff
there our transition defense needs to be
on point throughout the whole game so
this is kind of interesting like this
was the problem we were trying to solve
we kept looking at transition transition
and it turns out that this trio is
really no better than the rest that yes
but you know what stands out to me is on
the left half court offense now if you
recall from the team profile page they
were ranked 30th in league this trio is
significantly better this is great
information
because now I'm sorry seeing more of a
complete picture but I'm not done yet
yeah can we take a look at the look at
their con their efficiency what makes
them so good sure so the beauty of the
results from that last cell is that we
can then dive into additional
information so in this case we're gonna
start looking at their tendencies so
what do you see here so now I'm starting
a much more clear picture this team is a
pretty unselfish when it comes to
comparing them to the rest of the team
they do an excellent job with ball
movement and they utilize the half ball
screen at a high rate and you don't
dribble the ball much very efficient
style basketball yeah I I love this type
of data analysis we started with one
problem attempting to solve it and then
we found another one which ended up
leading
- real actionable insight and the fun
part is we are able to flip this 80/20
challenge around providing you more time
for insight discovery yes and I got one
question for you yeah how are you gonna
address this threat in the playoffs well
I know what I'm doing
okay can you share I can't tell you guys
I can I've shared enough today I playoff
series I'm trying to win all right man
but Bill thanks for being here today and
partnering with us on your smart
analytics journey good luck against the
SuperSonics and if you need any help
writing queries give me a call I
appreciate that thanks Eric thanks man
so before you go papel yeah we've been
talking a lot and asking people about
the fun part in the not fun part so when
you think about the whole journey data
scientists for you what's the real fun
part you know what it would be it
probably would be that's a good question
might it be this that's what it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Abell think eric thankfully faced Erin
and Emma that I can't talk the trophy so
we're just gonna wrap the demo derby and
bring Adam back up thanks everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh fantastic alright thanks to Greg and
everyone on the demo derby team over the
course the afternoon I hope a couple of
big ideas came across number one we love
developers whether you're building an
app running an ops team migrating a
database or figure out how to win
championships the people that put their
hands on the keyboards you're you're the
MVPs in any company the second is we
want to help you get to the fun part of
your job that you were excited back when
you first started being a developer and
then and then maybe the last thing we
want to help you
everything you see here we want to help
you spend less time on the everyday
hassles to get in the way and get in the
way if you're just being creative
solving problems learning new stuff for
growing your career so we've actually
got hundreds and even thousands of
engineers that work at Google on our
products and endeavor all and they're
eager to talk to you and hear about
you're here about your challenges and
your opportunities and help you with all
this technology
[Music]